all right to the monologue we look at
small things as trivial but in reality
the things we ignore come back to haunt
us look at me I was once a small thing
myself still AM another example a
scientific paper predicted that the
presence of SARS like viruses in bats
together with the practice of eating
them is a time bomb that warning was
from 2007 now a warning from me 2014 six
years ago in my book not cool on page
136 I warned readers of reusable
shopping bags that one study linked them
to a 46 percent increase in deaths from
foodborne illnesses they raised the risk
by harboring viruses that could go from
your bag to the food you share with your
family
reusable feed bags might have also
killed millions of piglets seven years
ago by spreading a novel swine virus
other research among humans shows how
viruses spread with similar bags making
people sick so why is this important
States banned plastic bags you're
supposed to rely on reusables which in a
time like this ain't good we're told to
steer clear of contaminated surfaces yet
we carry one to stores schools
workplaces and put our food in it right
now it makes sense to postpone these
bans hell we're postponing everything
else it's a vector we can easily control
so here's the good news we aren't
running out of food and we probably
won't the bad news those bags you put
that food in aren't helping some viruses
spread through good intentions gone bad
the best intention now is to ask for
single use bags plastic or paper so Dana
my wife comes home she's got the mask on
because we roleplay she's very healthy
very healthy does all those wet
hand-washing yells at me to take my
shoes off but she's holding the damn
bags the reusable bags with produce in
them yeah how do they and I think we
think that this is a good move but it's
not because we are I mean we there is
concern about plastics in the ocean
right that is a concern plastics in the
water is a concern but your book pointed
it out John Tierney City Journal has
been pointing out for years Kim Strasse
at The Wall Street Journal and so I
always think about this I don't like I
get plastic anxiety
as well as like with water bottles
things like that but this point about
the bags and carrying things around and
everything it knows that it causes more
problems and so the rethinking some of
these things it's not too like it's you
can you can do this you can turn back
things right away the president's
already shown this one of the things
they did in the last two days they
stopped in to the regulations that
didn't make sense in the first place
which was now doctors can work across
state lines yeah how about telemedicine
right there were regulations against
some of that and they by getting
government to get out of the way you
allow more competition and my my hope is
that there will be some super smart
people out there maybe like Reagan who's
there on the couch and a learning guitar
maybe I'll have this amazing innovative
idea to come up with a product and it's
a solution that will help us have more
biodegradable plastics that would be
ideal
yeah so Jesse the problem is is that we
have to rely on people like me to wash
my bags sometimes I wear the same gym
shirt three days in a row ah I just dry
it out on the shower Dana so I'm gonna
do that looks like people grab their bag
and they just go to the place and that's
the problem because you'd have to wash
this bag every day which is worse for
the environment because of the chemicals
you're using and I've read somewhere I
want to say something funny about your
role play comments yes I'm not gonna say
it
okay I think it's just smarter if I just
bite my tongue on that one yeah you
can't hold my hand not on social
distancing myself from gaffes listen
like you said at the top these you have
good intentions and then sometimes it
backfires remember they said you don't
want to clear the underbrush out of
these forests because it's bad well then
you have wildfires or they say you gotta
raise the minimum wage in the in New
York City and then they fire half the
waitresses so sometimes these things go
the wrong way I used to make fun of
people like
germophobes Jerry Seinfeld how many
episodes on Seinfeld did they make fun
of his fear of germs
I mean Kramer installing the garbage
disposal in the shower and make Jerry a
salad
or Elaine sneezes on the pasta primavera
and gets the NBC executive sick or Jerry
catches the chef not washing his hands
when he comes out of the bathroom these
are things that he is saying haha that's
funny but now you look back and say
Jerry was right this whole time we just
need to reevaluate everything that we've
been doing and after we beat this thing
we're gonna look back and say do we need
to start having more people work
remotely why are we living on top of
each other in these cities the handshake
is the handshake an outmoded concept in
this country
we're overly reliant on China the
borders are wide open all of these
things are gonna have to be reevaluated
one at a time Dagan should they did lay
the ban yet we shouldn't have the ban in
the first place it goes to your point
who is making these decisions about
banning plastic bags you know it's some
guy in a room going let's stick into the
oil and the chemical companies it's not
based on any research as you pointed out
that goes back with more than a decade
knowing that these these bags aren't
sanitary i banned the handshake a while
ago just to tell you because about one
out of every 20 dudes who shake your
hand want to do that weird little tickle
thing that's just creepy and then I'm
Greg I'll leave you with two words Darth
Vader very good so what I think the good
news is the problem here isn't food I
think we're going to do okay in this in
this industry it's the bag what how do
you feel should it be banned should be
banned be temporarily suspended yeah I
mean if you if you can identify it as a
source of spreading the virus I would I
think that what we what you said there
in describing it to the audience is it
often gets dirty filled up with microbes
you don't know what's in it and you said
it kills some piglets once right yeah so
I think that's very real now I do think
it's not a reason to say oh let's give
up on this idea because you know look I
think you can just look up in the trees
in Central Park or any Park in this
country you see plastic bags and you
know about the oceans so I think coming
up with biodegradable substances that
could make
Begg is a good idea I just don't want us
to use this as an opportunity to go back
on lots of our efforts in terms of
making sure that the environment the
fact that we see you know climate it's
rising
you know oceans rising we just can't
give up I think we got to stay focused
on what we're already doing make it
better don't allow that to somehow
communicate this terrible disease today
I was shocked I've tell you the truth I
was shocked and said 475 people died in
one day today in Italy I just it's hard
to believe this is what we're going
through as a world right now